ياخذون استراحه من ضراوه المعارك في مدينه
حمص الجبهه الاماميه تبعد مسافه قليله من
هنا واغلب هؤلاء الجنود يقاتلون منذ عده
اشهر في المنطقه الجيش السوري يشارك في
قتال الشوارع لاكثر من سنتين الان ولم يرد
الجنود التحدث الينا لانه لا يسمح لهم
بذلك الا انهم قالوا بانه من المستحيل ان
تضعف معنوياتهم اشتباكات بين خط الجبهه
ونقاط التفتيش المجنده مما يضعف صفوف
الجيش السوري ولكنه لا يزال مستعدا في
غالبيه المواجهات وخلال القتال تم الابلاغ
عن كثير من التجاوزات التي قام بها بعض
المقاتلين المنتمين لنظام الاسد كاستخدام
العشوائي للاسلحه الثقيله في مناطق سكنيه
وتقول الامم المتحده ان كلا من قوات
النظام والمعارضه ترتكب جرائم حرب وجرائم
ضد الانسانيه وفي حمص تبكي هذه العائله
على طفلها هذا هو علي سليمان يبلغ من
العمر ت عاما وهو جندي قتل قبل اسبوع
والدته تقول ان جثه ولدها لا تزال في ساحه
المعركه شع مط القلب لكن انا معه ايد بيد
انه يدافع عن الوط وانا سلمته لرب
العالمين سوريا النظام السوري يقول ان
الجيش يقاتل بشده قوات المعارضه الا ان
هناك خسائر فادحه في صفوف الجيش
ايضا هذا وقد تم السماح لنا بدخول
المستشفى العسكري في حمص اخر دفعه من الجن
هنا اصيبوا في هجوم انتحاري بقاعده عسكريه
والناجون قالوا بان 20 جنديا لقوا حذفهم
في الهجوم اول تفجير كان عند
الباب طلع احنا شفنا المنظر
يعني كانوا رفقاتنا
بالارض نحنا طالعين فات سياره كبيره انيه
وراها وصلنا نقاوم فات لجو المبن احد
الاطباء هنا يقول ان الفريق الطبي يتعامل
بشكل متزايد مع حالات الحروق الشديده وهذا
نتيجه الاستعمال المتزايد والعشوائي
للعبوات الناسفه من قبل المتشددين
المعارضين هال الارهاب اللي قدر
الامريكيين والاوروبيين يشوفوه بافغانستان
وشافوه بالعراق وميزو حتى بمالي وسمحوا
للجيش الفرنسي بمحاربته خارج
اراضيه مصرين على انه ما يشوفوا الارهاب
عننا المجتمع الدولي يقول ان الجيش السوري
ارتكب فضائع كثيره الا ان العديد من جنوده
دفع الثمن غاليا ايضا دفاعا عن نظام يقاتل
للبقاء على سده
الحكم